thank you
leech had something unique to it you
know a world that's closer to our own
teenage characters a stylish appeal the
themes that are presented in a blatantly
darker and more mature way compared to
the typical 2000s Shonen and of course
no shortage of exciting fights so with a
new season on its way it does take a
stroll down memory lane and look at what
I personally think are the top 10 bleach
fights I feel that it's only apt to
start the list with our protagonist
Ichigo faces his first major test in the
fight against Grant Fisher
foreign
let's keep it simple to start with shall
we ground Fisher is ichigo's first main
obstacle and the fight with this hollow
marks the first serious battle in Bleach
giving it a much desired break from the
simple episodic episodes with lower
Stakes with this being early in Bleach
the powers displayed are still very
simple very vanilla compared to what we
get accustomed to still I feel that this
fight belongs amongst the top fights of
bleach due to how it affects the status
quo and how character-driven this fight
was he had a lot of meaning it was also
this fight that gave us a glimpse of
ichigo's potential and which direction
he can go in terms of getting stronger
and finding his resolve
thank you
if you're up for a good Broad in Bleach
how about the battle between Kenpachi
and Neutra at number nine
again patchy and Neutra it's a match
made in heaven both battle hungry
representatives of each other's factions
it's a no-brainer to have their paths
crossed in the hueco Mundo Arc and it
was a bloodbath just as everyone
expected both Fighters slashed and
struck each other with their best blows
reaching the point of activating each
other's release forms eye patchless
Kenpachi taking on release Neutra was
the slugfest of heavyweights to remember
I feel that it belongs somewhere lower
on the list however because of how
anticlimactic the end of the fight feels
emotionally and with a bit of a backdrop
it's good but considering that Ken
baichu's new power up is something
simple as fighting with two hands feels
a little bit too tame then again it fits
his character perfectly and when
thousand year blood War comes you'll see
more craziness that's out for this
captain
oh
a lot of captains have great fights and
kiorako has one himself albeit late in
the show heck he reminds me of the
previous entry
versus Stark just like Kent Bachi versus
Neutra is a match that's very fitting
just like the previous one this one pits
a captain against his equivalent this
time it's the battle of the easy-going
but super strong combatants Stark is
named number one Espada for a reason and
he just finished a thrashing of two
visads as for kyoraku we haven't seen
too much of his Feats at this point but
know that he's a senior Captain who's a
lot nearer to Yamamoto cheer than people
would think this fight has a more
relaxed and Casual vibe to it all things
considered while the two are indeed
having a serious fight it does feel more
like a dance and a sharing of thoughts
of Wills Stark's unaggressive nature and
kioraku's Stern get calm demeanor
including his powers involving literal
child's games actually meshes well
together it's a good fight all in all
become Thousand-Year blood War you'll
know that it's not always all fun and
games for Captain kiraku as to what his
new abilities are I'll just leave you
guessing for those who haven't gotten
hold of spoilers yet
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to continue with the captain battles we
proceed with oriu versus Mayuri
insufferable genius meets insufferable
genius we're starting to see a pattern
here now aren't we or use personal
biggest highlight in the entire Bleach
anime so far would be this battle
against the Shinigami Captain it's the
long-awaited battle between Shinigami
and Quincy and add more Stakes to what's
already been a tense battle mayuri's
background was revealed making this
thing Ultra personal for uriu facing off
his first real challenge ever since
entering Soul Society uriu finds himself
in trouble for a lot of the fight thanks
to mayuri's terrifying Powers however he
does overcome all the debilitating
effects of Mayuri zanbacto only for the
mad scientist to reveal his grotesque
Bankai I guess in the end that makes
uru's crowning moment even more
satisfying with such insurmountable odd
stacked against him he decides to give
it his all before blasting the gigantic
baby away in an all-in attack despite
his strong billing or you never really
had a big achievement prior to this
fight after fighting Mayuri though he
sure has one now
oh
God
versus Thomson certainly deserves a spot
on the list
[Music]
before he was kicking ass in hueco mundo
Zaraki had been a wild card Our Heroes
first founded unlikely Ally in the soul
Society Arc in the form of the menacing
Kenpachi Zaraki as someone who doesn't
seem bound to the code of honors the top
Shinigami uphold with regards to the
impending execution zanaki is more than
willing to take on his complete opposite
though sent in a fight it's a clash
between methodical and the unrestrained
as though sen takes his sweet time
dancing around kenpati thanks to his
debilitating Bankai eventually
gambachi's instincts start adapting to
the situation and the fight ends up with
him turning the tide in a big way with
such a bold move it takes a real lunatic
to think of the strategy of getting
yourself stabbed to locate an opponent
but if there's a true madman and someone
Tough Enough To tank it out it's none
other than kempachi
to continue with the soul Society Arc
fights we have renji versus biakuya
renji and biakuya have quite the
interesting role as Captain and
Lieutenant instead of the expected
Superior subordinate relationship renji
has always seen his captain as a rival
an object to surpass and with his desire
to save rookie are taking priority renji
Finally Found A Fire Inside to train for
Bankai and finally defeat his captain
biakuya starts off looking down on renji
mentioning their sheer Gap in prowess
but he'd end up beating those words as
renji bravely puts on a great show
against him with his band guy renji puts
his captain on the ropes numerous times
but as the battle goes on you'll start
to notice something he's not actually
doing visible damage to biakuya piakuya
then releases his own Bankai and easily
defeats renji still this is a fight
that's all about the emotional stakes
and how it encapsulates renji's
character development what brings this
fight up is more of how it showcases the
Lieutenant's development and his
character but hey don't tell me that
giant bone snake ain't impressive
meaning
[Music]
up next we have Ichigo versus Eisen
[Music]
usually the final fight is pitching the
greatest villain of the story against
the protagonist is the best one out
there but not in this case Ichigo vs
Eisen has a lot of awesome sprinkled all
over it in terms of visual spectacle but
the fight itself isn't much of a fight
to be honest it's just 90 Ichigo
dominating Eisen despite the latter's
attempts to fight back we've got the
Callback of Ichigo stopping a sword with
his hand and we also get him breaking
through a full powered Black Coffin with
his hand too it's the Showcase of insane
feat as he forces Eisen to keep evolving
before unleashing the final getsuga 10
show it does feel so good to see Eisen
finally lose his call after spending so
many arcs being a step ahead of the
heroes after being so smug and so on top
of the situation for so long he's
finally met his match and the tables
have finally turned while the fight
itself isn't much to write home about if
we exclude the sheer satisfaction of
Ichigo doing well eyes and stuff against
Eisen its ending does make a fitting
conclusion to the ark and it allows
Ichigo to understand Eisen on a
different level than before
let's move on to Ichigo versus all Kiora
what turned out to be ichigo's toughest
challenge up to that point in the story
is All Kiora okiora and Ichigo have
clashed numerous times prior to their
final meeting in Las noches and the
Espada had come out on top every single
time and in each Victory Ichigo got
destroyed in increasingly severe ways
after all the power-ups and the
confidence boost he'd got through the
arc Ichigo still finds himself unable to
match up well to the mightiest spider in
fact this is the fight where Ichigo dies
the hardest yeah he had a lot of those
before once or Kiora even but it's
painful to see him get blasted that hard
in front of Orihime it's the ark's
darkest hour for sure and that makes
this fight so memorable what makes this
fight even more memorable however is the
appearance of ichigo's New Hollow form
the new form completely turns the tables
and squashes all Kiora even trivializing
his ultimate attack Ichigo had gone
completely wild and it's quite a sight
to see Wonder astonishment and fear
would be the emotions used to describe
this chilling scene that led to the
battle's conclusion
foreign
best bleach fight for me would be Ichigo
versus Grim gel
an epic rivalry deserves nothing but an
epic blow-off fight to conclude it in
the Aaron Carr Arc grimjao has long
served as ichigo's primary antagonist a
personal rival even yeah sure there's
the thing with rescuing Orihime from all
Kiora and the number for Espada
repeatedly stomping our hero but the
connection with grim gel felt a lot more
personal than natural he really does
remind me of a blue head renji if we're
talking about character archetypes but
this was at a point where the overall
power scale had increased so much
resulting in a much more spectacular
fight visually speaking that is people
have criticized this all for mirroring
Soul Society while changing the actors
and while I wouldn't completely disagree
with that the payoffs for some parts of
this Arc ended up being a lot better and
this fight is just one of them the fight
just carried so much hot-blooded
intensity and it finished grimdale's
character Arc while giving it a contrast
to Ichigo and the source of his
unrelenting will we also got the super
badass moment of Ichigo grabbing Grim
gel and are heavily injured protagonist
just powering his way through Grim gel's
ultimate attack for the Finish
number one is Ichigo versus biakuya
[Music]
you go versus yakuya is the climax that
great Arc like the soul Society are
deserved it's got everything you want
from a final boss fight the hype is
there for both Fighters the two have
been easily defeated multiple
lieutenants and shown their power and it
coincides with Ichigo first unveiling
his two most iconic abilities his
gitsugar tencho and his Bankai this is a
fight with a lot of emotional Stakes
good build up an excellent pacing all
throughout both also show of quite a bit
of their powers while we get more
character build up in the form of
ichigo's hollow taking over the fight
both Fighters take their turn grabbing
control of the momentum and while the
fight lasted quite a while it never felt
as if it's just pointless exchanges of
my power count as yours nope my power
count is yours as a total package this
fight had it all it's got one of the
most glorious endings with the two
making one final charge after Ichigo
fights out of his hollow form trying to
take over
I hope that the list is enough to bring
back those good memories and get you all
hyped up to watch the Epic conclusion of
the story in Bleach Thousand-Year blood
War it's coming soon and I can't wait
thank you for watching this video hope
to see you again for the next one more
anime goodness awaits so stay tuned stay
awesome
[Music]